怎么，
怎么舍得让自己的孩子放弃他的人生来陪伴我这样一个风烛残年的这样一个人生呢？
我怎么舍得让他去这么做呢？
我不舍得，
你也不舍得，
所以你要看清楚，
你妈妈能赚钱是他的本事，
他愿意留给谁就留给谁，
他愿意怎么花就怎么花，
不要惦记他的钱。
当我自己可以养活我和我的孩子的时候，
我和我的孩子都是自由的，
当我要惦记一个控制欲极强的妈妈的钱的时候，
我和我的孩子都是牺牲品，
都是他的玩具。
我是家里的独生女人，
个人存款里有60个W，
不在体制内，
并不是太光鲜亮丽的那种。
我父母的财产呢，
有1000个W，
但是呢，
我的妈妈呢，
她并不爱我，
她是NPP，
她有着非常严重的控制欲，
她已经用了1000万的他的这个诱饵，
让我在我的人生的重大决策当中做了很多就是他满意但是让我很痛苦的角色，
在我去年离婚之后，
我突然间清醒了，
我想做一个独立的人，
我打算脱离他对我人生的掌控，
这样按照就是法律要求赡养他的同时，
尽量远离他的这种对我的控制，
把我的注意力放在我和我的孩子身上，
我的妈妈多次就是多次威胁我，
他做我结婚的时候说就她后悔只生了我一个孩子，
如果当初他要是多生几个的话，
给他养老就。
方便了，
而且以后他遗产也会有个竞争，
还说某某老人因为保姆照顾的好，
最后钱把自己的房产给了保姆，
然后他说他随便把房子给谁，
谁都能给他好好的养老安全，
马后把他当皇帝一样供着。
我认为这是他对我的三角测量，
然后在我离婚之后呢，
我情绪也不大对，
我就控诉他曾经对我的控制，
他就威胁我说如果我再不听话，
他以后的钱就一分都不给我，
我觉得他就是对我竞选的一种惩罚，
他还问我说能不能在他老了以后专门辞职，
专门照顾他，
我不想辞职，
我就拒绝了，
他就很生气，
他说生孩子就是为了养老的，
如果孩子都不听他的话，
那他做父母也就没什么意思了，
这么多年他对我的教育也就只有听话，
还有就是别惹事儿，
然后还笑我哭穷，
说他连买菜的钱都没有了，
还有就是洗脑，
这个世界上只有父母对你好最让我接受不了的事。
当时他催我要孩子，
然后我的孩子出生了，
是个男孩儿，
他说他出生真是太享福了，
以后那么多钱不给他给谁呀？
结果以后的时候说扔给他爸爸，
等他长大了之后，
你再找他一句，
你给他个十万八万的，
他就来认里他当时我都震惊了，
他在想会不会他的遗产传到我这里也就没多少了呀。
前段时间他跟我说找到谁都没有用，
一切都得靠他自己，
自己要赶紧提前把钱享受完，
还诅咒我说我可能。
比他先，
可能我的孩子比他先，
我听到这句话我就无语了，
他天天说我以后的钱都是你的，
这句话是不是虚无缥缈的？
所以我想理解的一个问题就是，
假如说我以后想就是变得心理健康，
人格独立的话，
我是不是应该就当他这笔钱不存在，
还是说我应该去争取一下，
应该当他不存在？
没有惦记就没有痛苦，
有惦记有期待就会有痛苦，
没有惦记就没有痛苦。
其实当我听到你妈妈说她生病了，
让你辞职回来照顾他这件事情的话，
我就问你，
如果你生病了，
你将来会要求你的孩子辞职回来照顾你吗？
前提条件，
你有1000万，
你会要求你的孩子辞职回来，
天天伺候你吃，
伺候你穿，
天天围着你吗？
其实我有1万块钱，
我也不会让他回来，
这就是我们两个人拿能达成的共识，
我们怎么舍得让自己的孩子放弃他的人生来陪伴我这样一个风烛残年的这样一个人生呢？
我怎么舍得让他去这么做呢？
我不舍得，
你也不舍得。
所以你要看清楚，
你妈妈能赚钱是他的本事，
他愿意留给谁就留给谁，
他愿意怎么花就怎么花，
不要惦记她的钱。
当我自己可以养活我和我的孩子的时候，
我和我的孩子都是自由的，
当我要惦记一个控制欲极强的妈妈的钱。
的时候，
我和我的孩子都是牺牲品，
都是他的玩具。
刘慧姐，
我还有一个问题，
可能在三年以前给我写过一份遗嘱，
然后遗嘱上面说遗产只给我一个人，
但是我今天就是在网上遗查，
就是网上说就是可能这份遗嘱是一个无效的，
嗯，
他的见证人是我的父亲，
也就是说是一个和我有着利害关系的人，
这是一个他的手写遗嘱，
我想问一下他是有效的还是无效的，
是这样啊，
遗嘱这个东西你可以随时变，
随时换，
随时改，
所以我说你别惦记他，
那个遗嘱你可以先放着，
你爸爸还在吗？
他们都身体都挺健康，
而且我妈妈的身体比我还好，
如果你爸爸还在的话，
那么这一天了当中一半是你爸爸的，
一半是你妈妈的。
嗯，
就这个意思，
你别惦记，
别惦记，
如果说将来真的去世了，
没有遗嘱的情况下，
也是法定的来继承你或许有意外之财，
我懂了，
就是如果有的话，
就是一个惊喜，
然后没有的话，
我就好好的生活，
靠着自己的努力也能给自己和孩子挣口饭吃，
是我也是这么想的，
我懂了，
好再见啊，
拜拜拜。
其实控制型的父母挺多的，
有多少人是被控制型的父母控制着。
人生扣1，
有的父母会偷偷的改孩子的志愿，
本来孩子能考上清华北大，
他偷偷的改到他们。
县城的一个师范大学，
就是为了在身边给自己养老，
有的父母是明明这个孩子可以在北上广深这样的城市立住脚，
他就怕孩子不给自己养老，
非得让孩子回到县城里头考个公务员，
考个教师，
这个也不是说个别的父母的问题，
这是我们整个文化环境的产物，
也是整个经济环境的产物。
今天讲这个话可能讲的有点深刻了啊，
我自认为是深刻的，
比如我的父母，
他们养我也是图回报的，
也是图我给他养老的，
但我也能理解他们，
我为什么能理解他们，
我跟大家讲一下，
分析一下这底层的逻辑，
是因为他们所存在的那个年代，
物资是极其匮乏的，
他们所能挣回来的钱，
要么就是供孩子上学，
要么就是自己存着养老，
他如果不供孩子上学的话，
他可以给自己养老，
但是他选择了供孩子上学，
他就没有能力给自己养老了。
你们的父母可能也是生在那样的匮乏的物资匮乏的年代，
但是像我现在对我的孩子，
我就不图他的回报，
不要他给我养老，
原因是我生在了一个物资发展极其丰富的时代，
制造业发展极其蓬勃的时代，
因为我现在是靠自己的双手和能力，
既可以赡养父母，
又可以养育子女，
还可以给自己储备养老的钱，
因为好多姐妹其实不管你是当个老师。
知也好，
你是当个护士也好，
当医生也好，
你只要有一份体面的工作，
你现在就可以做到既能养活孩子，
又能给自己养老了，
我们这一代人才有可能真真正正的不图回报的去爱孩子，
我们的上一辈人，
他们是做不到不图回报的爱孩子的，
就是这么个情况，
所以我经常跟他们大家说，
我的爸妈养我一场，
是图我给他们养老，
我也接纳这一点，
我也愿意做这个事情，
是因为我深层的去理解了他们那一代人物资是匮乏的，
他们没有这个能力既要育子女，
又照顾自己的养老生活，
尤其是农村的，
他们没有这样的能力做这件事情。
记得点赞关注哦。